but I didn't want to hear the end
without taking you off for coming out to
the theater and thank you for supporting
Top Gun language
Tom Cruise took to the skies to
celebrate the nearly 1.5 billion
worldwide box office of top gun Maverick
making it the number one movie this year
Tom thanked the fans by jumping from a
helicopter high above South Africa while
filming the next installment in the
mission impossible series Cruz was
joined by Christopher McQueary director
of the upcoming Mission Impossible dead
reckoning who was also the screenwriter
for top gun Maverick
as always thank you for allowing us to
entertain you it truly is the honor of a
lifetime Cruz is well known for
performing his own stunts famously
hanging off the side of a plane for
Mission Impossible Rogue nation in 2015.
while plummeting to the ground Crews
took the time to wish his fans a happy
holiday season I better get back to work
we gotta get this shot
you have a very safe and happy holiday
we'll see at the moments